Speaker 1: Hello, everybody, and welcome to
The David Pakman Show. I'm producer Pat Forde,
filling in for David today as he is spending some
time today on the studio redesign. You may know by
now that we're coming out with a new studio for
you guys in the next few, I don't know, weeks,
months, something like that. And the panels are
going right in the trash. No more panels. We're
going to be doing something new. So he's working
on that today. He'll be back with us tomorrow. I
wanted to start things off today by talking
about this big story we heard over the long
holiday weekend here in the United States. And
that is that Kanye West was seen with Nick Fuentes
at an airport together and it was confirmed
that they were going to visit Donald Trump,
the failed former president at Mar a Lago.
Now, this is a big deal, of course, because
Nick Fuentes is a flat out racist, anti-Semitic
person, political commentator. He's so far to the
right that even other people on the right denounce
him because, you know, he's just full mask off,
right. He's a Holocaust denier. He wants Trump
to be made dictator like all the worst things
that you can get on the right. Kanye West, of
course, is the famous rapper who decided to throw
his career away earlier this month and become
a social pariah, also that he could, you know,
publicly say these anti-Semitic things and claim
that he was going to go def con three on Jewish
people. So Trump thought that it would be a good
idea to have dinner with these two people. And as
you may imagine, the Trump 2024 presidential
campaign team is going absolutely ballistic
over this. They're in full on damage control mode
because this is just not the right way to start
off your campaign dining with a couple of out and
out anti-Semites. So Trump put out a statement
about all this on Truth Social, and this is how
it all got organized, according to him. He said,
quote, This past week, Kanye West called me to
have dinner at Mar a Lago. Shortly thereafter,
he unexpectedly showed up with three of
his friends whom I knew nothing about. We
had dinner on Tuesday evening with many members
present on the back patio. The dinner was quick
and uneventful. They then left for the airport. So
Trump here being very much dismissive of the three
people that Kanye brought with him to the dinner,
he's trying to say, Oh, well, I can't be guilty
by association because I didn't even know these
people. But really just having Kanye over alone is
enough to make you worthy of public scrutiny. It's
a sign that you've gone too far because he's just
said some horrible things over the past few weeks
that have rightfully got him canceled. You know,
all these things about how he's going to go
def con three on Jewish people and all these
anti-Semitic tropes that he repeats and repeats.
And it's not like one of those things where you
have a celebrity who says something dumb and then
they apologize for it. The next day they say, Oh,
I was drunk when I wrote that. That's not how I
really feel. And I'm going to make every effort
to make amends. Now, Kanye has just said horrible
things and continued saying horrible things. He
keeps doubling down on these shows and on
Twitter and all these different stuff. So,
I mean, having Kanye over at this point, it's just
completely toxic. You used to be able to trot him
around in these rightwing circles, like Candace
Owens would go around the country with him. And
there was talk about how he's a Trump supporter.
And, you know, he'd go on Tucker Carlson show and
all these different things. You really can't be
associated with him anymore, even if you're on the
right. So this excuse that Trump gives that, oh, I
only knew Kanye, I didn't know the other visitors.
Kanye is enough to make you look bad. There's
also a great amount of dispute over whether Trump
actually didn't know the other three guests that
Connie brought with him since Karen Giorno was one
of them. And she was Trump's campaign director
in the state of Florida in 2016, he apparently
knows her by name and site. So if he lied about
that, what else could he be lying about it? I get
the sense that he probably knew who Nick Fuentes
was, even though he declares that he didn't know
who Nick Fuentes was. Maybe he knew that Fuentes
isn't the type of person you don't want to admit
to knowing. But I do get the sense that Trump
probably knew who he was. Fuentes was there,
by the way, because he was advising Kanye West in
his 2024 presidential campaign, which we found out
about last week, that that's a thing that Kanye is
giving another shot at becoming president. And he
has people like Nick Fuentes and Milo Yiannopoulos
working for him. As for the dinner, Trump had
planned to dine privately with Kanye at Mar a Lago
library, but then they decided that they should
all eat outside on the public patio. No word
yet as to what they had for dinner. I don't know
about the appetizer and entrees selection, but who
knows? Maybe we'll get some more updates on that.
But as to what they talked about at the dinner,
Kanye actually had the gall to ask Trump to be
his running mate during this whole exchange. So
Kanye invited himself over effectively to Trump's
house. At least that's the theory that we have.
That's the story we're being told on this. And
he decided to tell Trump who he knows is running
for president himself, that he, Kanye West,
is also running for president and may take some
share of the Trump vote. And then on top of that,
Kanye wants Trump to bend the knee to him at his
own house and become his vice president. Like,
how crazy is that? Kanye just full of. Arrogance
here, not understanding that Trump is the alpha
dog currently in Republican politics. And he's not
just going to back Kanye for no reason and become
his VP. Just absolutely insane. You cannot make
this stuff up, folks. And we actually have Kanye
talking about his encounter with Trump. Let's cut
to that now and listen to some of the other things
that Kanye says went down at that dinner.
Speaker 2: I think the thing that Trump was
most perturbed about, me asking
him to be my vice president,
I think that was like lower on the list of things
that caught him off guard. Then he goes on to say
that Kim is. Tell her I said that. And I was
thinking like, that's the mother of my children.
Since we know and all the Christians in America
that love Trump know that Trump is a conservative.
We're going to demand that you hold all policies
directly to the Bible. When Trump started
basically screaming at me at the table telling me
I was going to lose. I mean, has that ever worked
for anyone in history? You're going to lose.
You're going to lose. I'm like, Whoa, whoa, hold
on, hold on. Trump You're talking to. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So there's that trademark arrogance
on display with Kanye West. He thinks he can just
show up to Trump's residence at Mar a Lago and ask
him to be his VP and that Trump wouldn't get mad
or anything like that. Of course, Trump got mad
because he has this giant ego and both of these
people have crazy egos. Like if you put them in
a room together, some wacky situation is going
to stir up. And in this case, it was not a room,
but a back patio. But nonetheless, some crazy
things resulted from it. Also pretty wild if
we're to believe, Kanye, that Trump would attack
Kim Kardashian for no apparent reason, no relevant
reason anyway. And we also learned from this
campaign ad we just watched that Kanye West
wants to make America a theocratic nation, to be
a Christian nation. And it's just added layers of
what's a crazy story that we don't even have time
to get into today. The fact that Trump apparently
attacked Kim Kardashian and the fact that Kanye
wants to make the U.S. a nationalist country or
a Christian nationalist country, rather. So Trump
is full on in damage control because his campaign
must have gone to him and said, you know, you
really should not have had these people over.
So he took to Truth Social yesterday to respond to
some of the backlash about Kanye. And he couldn't
even really do that properly because he brought up
Kanye's race for no apparent reason. He said this,
quote, So I help a seriously troubled man who
just happens to be black. Yeah, Kanye West, who
has been decimated in his business and virtually
everything else. And he has always been good to
me by allowing his request for a meeting at Mar a
Lago alone so that I can give him very much needed
advice. So Trump effectively here saying that he
doesn't care, that Kanye has said these horrible
anti-Semitic things because he's been nice to
Trump, and that's all that matters in Trump's
world. Now, the other key takeaway from the dinner
is that Trump was reportedly very much impressed
with Nick Fuentes. He said something like, He
really gets me. And he seemed very much taken
by Fuentes, who was able to rattle off statistics
and recall speeches, quotes from Trump speeches
going back to his 2016 presidential campaign. At
one point, Trump asked Fuentes what he thought
about his presidential announcement speech that
he gave a couple of weeks ago. And Fuentes said
that he should rely less on the teleprompter and
he needed to be higher energy, which actually
was true. Trump was very much low energy in that
announcement speech. Fuentes also told Trump that
he's going to crush the competition in the 2024
election, the Santos included, which, as you might
imagine, Trump liked very much. But it all just
adds a very strange layer of complexity to this,
because Fuentes is supposedly there because he's
advising Kanye West for for Kanye's presidential
campaign. So why is he giving Trump pointers and
telling him he's going to crush the competition
and all these different things like this is just
a complete Gong Show here. Trump also asked if
Fuentes was on Truth Social, which he said. Nick
Phenix said that he is untrue. Social and a bunch
of other social media sites had kicked him off for
being too, quote, French. So that, all in all, was
the dinner. There's still the question over how
much the Trump campaign is going to be affected by
this. Like, well, Republicans even care about this
sort of thing because, like Trump will repeatedly,
routinely make these unforced errors, do stuff
like this where he shoots himself in the foot and
he'll just be able to get beyond it. Like people
forget about it after a few weeks or so. Every
time we wonder us on the left, like, will this
time be different? Will this be one of the things
where Trump went too far and even Republicans turn
on him? But it never happens. It at least hasn't
happened for the past six years, and there's been
some crazy things going on in that six years,
like coup attempts and these types of things.
Will this be any different? My initial sense
is no. But on the other hand, if there's a case
to be made for this, actually torpedoing Trump's
early chances here of at least, you know, just
drowning out the competition and having an easy
road to the nomination, it's that he's already
a wounded antelope, like he had a disastrous
midterm performance. So many of his candidates
lost in their midterm bids. The Murdochs aren't
supporting him anymore, so he's not getting
favorable coverage on places like Fox News. He
has Ron DeSantis surging behind him in the polls
and in the betting markets. Some polls and betting
odds even have the Santos up. And there's just not
a lot of energy behind Trump's 2024 campaign. So
there's the potential that an inviting environment
like this where Trump is already doing so poorly
and has so many different things working against
him, maybe this is the type of thing that can
get a lot of attention and demand. His hopes
of being able to make a lock on this thing,
like to just completely secure the nomination
for himself, any other politician, this would
probably torpedo their chances. But we've seen
Trump get beyond these types of things before,
and ultimately he'll probably be able to
do it again. All right. We're going to go
to a break now. We'll be back with much more
of the David Pakman show right after this.